so we're continuing to see a sort of
fracturing or a balkanization for lack
of a better term of the republican party
and um i mentioned this earlier and i
want to spend a little more time on it
now
you always used to sort of have three
wings of the republican party
you've got that pro-business low tax
wing
that may have been socially conservative
but they didn't really care too much
about the social issues um exemplified
by people
sort of like mitt romney although romney
as a mormon it also seems to be a social
conservative but maybe less so than some
of the others but it's the pro-business
low-tax wing you then had the
libertarian right
so-called the the pro-liberty wing of
the republican party
exemplified by people like rand paul and
others of that ilk
and then you had the more extreme
evangelical religious right of the party
which was exemplified by folks like
i don't even know you know louis gomer
ted cruz people like that
where they may have had conservative
economics beliefs but really their
worldview was informed
along the lines of social issues and by
religion
trumpism caused a sort of realignment
in which the simplified factions became
pro-trump republicans and anti-trump
republicans at least during the trump
era and
you had pro-trump republicans from all
three of those factions
and anti-trump republicans from all
three of those factions as well
sometimes it was less about anti-trump
but just kind of like trump skeptical
or trump agnostic in some sense
we are now seeing the pro-trump side
further fracture into people who are
pro-trump but realize that the cartoons
of the party like matt gates
marjorie taylor green lauren bobert
these are bad for them
and then you've got the pro-trump people
doubling down
and supporting the gates and the marjory
taylor greens and these types of people
this weekend there was an event that i
guess was part of the
america first tour at which
matt gates spoke and marjorie taylor
green spoke
and not only are the events themselves
absolutely insane
the interviews with the attendees are
even more outrageous
this took place at the villages in
florida
a real trumpian enclave so first off
without even getting into the substance
it's a crowded room with matt gates
signs
with queens we are the champions blaring
i can't imagine queen as a band or any
of the band members would find
any common cause politically with these
clowns i'm not even playing the audio
because of copyright reasons okay so the
whole setup is crazy
then marjorie taylor green speaks and
she is still
going on about the so-called perfect
trump phone call
because the democrats impeached
president trump
over a perfect phone call by the way
these are parodies of themselves
at this point a skit of what such an
event
would look like would be no different
than the actual event
matt gates then portrays the entire fbi
investigation
into his possible child sex trafficking
as nothing but a politically motivated
witch hunt which
ignores that the investigation started
when donald trump was president
and then he actually praises the
completely discredited project veritas
like
any whatever crazy thing you imagine
they could say
they said all of it at this event
we have a right to confront our accusers
in this country how about that there can
be no due process here
if the only process due to conservatives
is to see leaks embroidered on to lies
than just endlessly repeated by the
america last
media
[Applause]
[Music]
i hope you guys show the thousand people
outside that wanted to be in here to
hear this message
but there are sometimes exceptional
journalists
who turn the cameras on to the liars
and in that vein let me say thank god
for project veritas
so there is no reason there is no common
sense there is none of it to be found
anywhere here and as you can probably
tell
uh uh it is not exactly
an event with deep political theory
presented or philosophical thought or
anything like it
for me the best part is the interviews
with the attendees
listen to this interview with a couple
outside the event
you guys both genuinely believe the
election was stolen
yes i mean that's you know if you
believe that that's true
that is that horrible yeah yeah i know
it is horrible
is it horrible that we would even be in
the situation to even think that
but it's false no it's not why would
they have all those
ballots hidden under tables why did that
man drive that truck
all the way across state lines all of
those
ballots under the table why did
that man drive across state lines
what what and the reporter tries
telling them this stuff has been
debunked it makes no difference take a
look
the palace under table thing with
giuliani in georgia that's all been
proven to be false
it has not i watched it on tv listen she
that's
that's pretty watertight you know she
saw it all on tv
that's all there is to it and of course
wear on tv
is a relevant question was it on newsmax
before newsmax
got the lawsuit threats and had to
apologize and take back a lot of what
they said
was it on fox news's lou dobbs show
before
he had to apologize and ultimately was
kicked off the air for the constant
propaganda debunked propaganda that was
being spread we don't know
where on tv she saw it but we've got
some pretty good guesses
you know i i i saw mr ed on tv
i believe horses can talk change my mind
it's right there you can see it
how does this all get dealt with at a
systemic level
that's the question i've been asking for
some time
and i don't know the answer i don't know
the answer but it is
really bad and i these people vote
it's their right i'm not suggesting we
take that right away we just have to
understand the reality that
many of these people vote some don't but
many do